c'est conscient dira alors si
aujourd'hui je ne doute pas qu'ils
puissent constater ce que nous avions
prévu à partir du moment où la droite
avait gagné les municipales
c'est normal ça se traduisent
aujourd'hui au sénat par ags et un
nombre de sénateurs
c'est mécanique ça a été vrai à
versements lorsqu'il y avait une
alternance au sénat ce que je pensais
que le sénateur larcher aujourd'hui a
dit être prêt à ne pas négocier
né à discuter et ce que je crois c'est
qu'au sénat maintenant tout va se jouer
texte par texte va bien voir sur les
réformes des réformes de la régulation
professionnelle
on a vu que j'aurais d'un contre-pouvoir
parlementaire indispensable donc ça peut
être difficile de travailler avec la
majorité au sénat
écoutez ce n'est pas le rôle du sénat
ted un couteau d'un contre-pouvoir le
rôle du sénat vous déchirer le contrat
chez ce soir je ne partage pas cette
idée d'un contre-pouvoir aujourd'hui je
crois que la france a besoin du maximum
de force pour pouvoir se transformer et
que l'idée d'un contre-pouvoir n'est pas
vraiment très efficace pour l'avenir de
notre pays aujourd'hui en 2011